and since we're on the subject of
governor government policies that kill
people we'll go now to
the governor's race in virginia where
terry mcauliffe
uh another guy who's been
sniffing in positions of power or
sniffing at power for
decades the the dude just won't go away
and now he's running for a governor of
virginia again
[Music]
and they had a debate last night he was
asked about uh late term abortion
specifically so this is third trimester
abortion
these are babies who are
fully developed they are quote-unquote
viable
meaning they could survive outside the
womb
um
how does he feel about abortion in that
case and here's what he says about it
so the issue here is in order for a
woman to get an abortion in the third
trimester you have to have a primary
doctor certify and then you have to have
two other doctors the problems you have
in rural parts of our state is there are
not three doctors so that really puts
women in rural communities at a real
disadvantage so if they came up with a
solution in a woman's life has to be in
danger has to be certified if you have a
legitimate doctor that says this woman
her life's in danger of course i would
support that i'll do anything i can and
that's the difference
my opponent as you know wants to ban
abortions he has said that he got caught
secretly on tape saying i will go on
offense i will go on offense to defund
planned parenthood and ban abortions and
then he said oh but we're not going to
tell the voters about it because if they
find out the independents won't vote for
me but don't worry i won't go squishy on
it i can tell you this to women watching
tonight i was a brick wall
i kept our 16 women's clinics open when
i was governor of the commonwealth of
virginia and if we allow this texas law
i can tell you this
amazon google facebook thank you it's
dangerous for a woman's life but it also
is crippling to the virginia economy
these high-tech companies here
okay so let's let's kill fully developed
infants
we know the left they when it comes to
abortion they prefer to talk about the
hard cases they prefer to talk about
you know rape and incest that's what
they want to
they want this entire discussion to be
centered around less than far less than
one percent of all abortions
they also prefer to talk about abortions
very early on
in pregnancy
um
but
the truth is that every single one of
them
i mean anyone who is pro-abortion or
quote-unquote
pro-choice anyone who identifies
themselves in in the year 2021
as pro-choice
it means that they support abortion
through all phases of pregnancy
there are rare exceptions to that
mccullough certainly is not an exception
now
the way that they dress it up is by is
this whole bit about it's only to save
the life of the mother
you need to understand and i will and i
will continue to clarify this every
single time it comes up
that is a
a fantasy
okay
that that category of abortion does not
exist
it is never
underlined here never necessary to have
an abortion
in the third trimester of pregnancy or
at any trimester but we're talking about
the third trimester
it is never necessary
to have a late term abortion to save the
life of a mother never
okay
there are certainly
things that can happen in a pregnancy
where a woman's
life is in jeopardy
and it means that the pregnancy has to
be ended
but there are
two ways in fact i'm like actually
there's only one way
in in the third trimester of pregnancy
if you want to end a pregnancy there's
only one way to do it
and that is to deliver the baby
the question is whether you kill the
baby before delivering him
that's an extra step
there is no medical reason to do it
so if a woman has a catastrophic health
complication which certainly does happen
and the doctor says you're gonna die um
if we don't deliver this baby and the
baby will probably die too
then yeah obviously you're gonna deliver
the baby there is no reason why you have
to kill the baby first
no reason
that's an extra step
if anything it's gonna it's gonna be
more dangerous for the mother now
because you're taking this extra step
rather than simply
taking the baby out
now we should also remember that um
life of the mother i mean everything
these people say you you can't take any
word they use or any phrase they use at
face value never make the mistake of
doing that
because we know that real life of the
mother abortions never happen
and would never need to happen
so what are they actually talking about
well when you look at this is the case
in virginia uh it's you know any of
these states when you
you look at the the language and the
laws and the policies what do you mean
by life of the mother
what you're going to find is that they
take a very expansive view
about life of the mother cases
and oftentimes you're going to find that
you know if a mother's
emotional
you know if she's being if she thinks
that having a baby would jeopardize her
emotional health or her psychological
health
or even her financial health
then that counts as a life of the of the
mother situation for an abortion
in other words
any reason
what anything could be affirmed as uh
uh as you know
a life of the mother
any reason a mother comes up with
in the third trimester to get an
abortion they can find a way to make
that a life of the mother situation
that's the reality
now so that was terry mcauliffe
let's go over to his opponent this guy
glen younkin
and you can see if you're watching the
video here you can see terry mcauliffe
points to glenn and accuses glenn of
being wanting to ban abortion
he makes this uh this slanderous claim
that glenn thinks that we should not
kill any babies
but glenn once glenn the republican
wants to make it very clear that this is
not true and that he in fact supports
killing babies in many circumstances
uh let's listen to his answer
this is an incredibly sensitive and
personal topic um
and i do appreciate the fact that you
would like to write legislation with me
um i think the texas bill is one that is
the standard right now that we're all
looking at and i would not sign the
texas bill today
as i've said through this entire
campaign i'm pro-life
i believe in exceptions in the case of
rape and incest and when the life of the
mother is in jeopardy
but the texas bill also also was
unworkable and confusing
what we're not doing this evening is
talking to my opponent about his extreme
views
see my opponent doesn't want to talk
about this topic tonight because
he actually called legislation that
would enable abortion paid for with
taxpayer money all the way up through
and including birth
where a child is kept comfortable while
decision is made where that child lives
or dies he called that legislation
common sense legislation and said he
would sign it
uh
i haven't looked at the polls in
virginia i don't need to look at the
polls i can already tell you
that this joker is going to lose and
deserves to
this brand of republicanism has been a
loser for decades
even more of a loser now
i mean it's never been appealing to
the left
it's never been appealing to the blessed
independence that you're trying to win
and more and more conservatives and
people on the right are just fed up with
it so
you're not really appealing to anyone
rather than then he's got an opportunity
here in this debate
with voters watching
to stand up there and make the case
against abortion to explain
why he is allegedly pro-life
it's not that hard to do
yeah he could say all he wants is this
is an incredibly personal
and complicated it's not complicated
it's not even personal really
it's very simple
it's not hard if you're a republican or
it shouldn't be to stand up there and
say listen
i believe
that it is never okay to intentionally
destroy innocent human life that's what
i believe
and that principle for me holds true for
all human life at all stages of
development
that's not hard to say
it shouldn't be hard to say
and that's that is an argument that the
other that snake on the other side there
terry mcauliffe he has no response for
that what you do is you flip it around
and you say uh terry
so you believe that sometimes it can be
okay to intentionally destroy innocent
human life and then he's going to say
well no that's not what i'm saying okay
well then explain to me
the baby in the womb
is that is it not a human
is it not a member of the human species
what species is it
what is it an aardvark
what it would i mean what is an octopus
what if it's not a human then what is it
well of course it's a human okay is it
not living
if it's not living then why do we need
the abortion to kill it
oh so so it is a human life and so you
do think that it's okay some sometimes
to intentionally destroy innocent life
that's your position that's not mine
that shouldn't be hard to do glenn
but instead he immediately goes on the
defensive and says well yeah i mean i'm
pro-life but uh but i still think that
that weak there's pl look listen guys
there's plenty of babies we could still
kill okay i'm on board with killed a lot
of different babies
it's my opponent he's the extreme one
let's talk about his extremism
somebody gives a damn about extremism
you call someone does this extreme i
wish you were extreme that's what we
want you should be extremely pro-life
stand up there and say yeah i'm an
extreme i am an extremist i am extremely
pro-life
he's an extremist he's extremely
anti-life so you voters have a choice do
you want someone who's extremely
pro-life or extremely anti-life
this uh
spineless
jellyfish routine it just it's it's not
going to cut it anymore it has never cut
it
it's never been a winner
republicans were able to get away with
it at least for a time and and sometimes
win elected office playing that with
that routine
not anymore
[Music]
there's there's no appetite for it
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
the matt well show if you did go ahead
and hit that subscribe button right down
there so you can stay up to date on all
of our future content